I wouldn't be bothering you here but your
people keep telling me you're unavailable
you know you really could
be doing more for this city
my family has a history of philanthropy but
as far as i can tell you're not doing anything
the riddler is asking for you the killer left
this for the batman why is he writing to you
you came i've been trying to reach you good
there's latest it's all about the wings if we
don't stand up no one will you got a lot of cats
everything about strength the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend of
yours i'm not so sure i'm just here
to unmask the truth about this cesspool
we call a city you're part of this too
how am i part of this oh you're really not
as smart as i thought you were bruised away
all these years you lied to me alfred we
all have our scars bruce you're still away
he's involved in this oh he's not involved how do
you know she suffered delaney who are you under
there what are you hiding selena don't throw your
life away don't worry honey i get nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied it's your violence
you may find justice the answer's justice
come on vengeance let's get into some trouble
Welcome back everyone this will be my new video
for the batman trailer they just released there's
a bunch of new footage in easter egg so we'll
break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll just start at the beginning of this and work
our way through shot by shot talking about easter
eggs and wtf moments as we go through the trailer
footage but it looks like they start with a new
scene of this new candidate for mayor talking
to bruce wayne this woman seems like she's the
candidate for the new mayor after the old one
is killed by the riddler i believe that's what
they're doing at the beginning of the trailer
here all the people are gathered for the mayor's
funeral as the riddler is about to attack them
again and she's just raking bruce wayne over the
coals a little bit because she claims that his
family the waynes historically have done a lot
of philanthropy for the city like traditional
philanthropy but he has not so she's asking him
to do that again in the funny way they cut his
reaction into this between the footage of her
grilling him about not doing anything for the
city in all the separate scenes of his car chase
with the penguin when he's going after him with
the batmobile just blowing up everything along
the highway just driving through a whole bunch
of stuff just destroying everything in his
path as he's trying to take down the penguin
and then cutting back to him in this conversation
just chuckling a little bit like haha not doing
anything for the city when she's talking about
his people she means all the people that run
wayne industries all of his support staff all the
people like alfred who are sort of like a buffer
between him and just regular people on the street
because even though he's spending all of his time
as batman this is like batman year two so he's
still in the thick of becoming the version of
batman that we know from the comics there's
still all the regular daily business of wayne
industries going on in the background which
he's just completely uninterested in the way
robert pattinson and matt reeves had talked about
batman during this movie is that he has absolutely
no interest in the bruce wayne persona he has no
interest in being bruce wayne so if you just break
down the number of scenes in the costumes that
he has he spends way more time in this movie in
batman persona in batman mode than he does in
bruce wayne mode this is him just arriving at
the mayor's funeral in his classic i believe is
a corvette i'm not a huge car person so i don't
know which year this is but because he is bruce
wayne he's a billionaire it is a batman movie
this is just a particularly collectible corvette
like a very valuable one if you've seen any of the
behind the scenes of the flash movie with michael
keaton's batman coming back for that the older
version of batman i believe he drives a maybach
during that movie so it wouldn't be a batman movie
batman wasn't driving really awesome cars all
kinds of different cars not just the batmobiles
this is also his garage too where he takes
gordon while he's wearing the batman costume
like you see all of his classic cars here in
his batmobile in this movie is mostly just a
souped-up muscle car that he's heavily modified
but it seems like he destroys it on the regular
almost every night that he takes it out but he's
a billionaire so what are extra car parts to him
this brand new scene in what seems like one of
the riddlers crime scenes or maybe the riddler's
apartment that they find with this big map on the
ground it's just a map of gotham city where it
says a real change and that's just a reference to
change in gotham like the riddler's whole thing in
this movie even though he's one of the traditional
batman villains is that he's trying to root out
all this corruption in gotham city during this
carmine falcone is the most powerful mob member in
the city but there's also the idea that there are
several other corrupt figures in the government
the mayor being one of them as well as gil coulson
who's the city prosecutor as well as the current
chief of police pete savage who's this character
here you can see yelling at gordon about batman
being at their riddler crime scene like what is he
doing here he's a vigilante like he hates the idea
of batman they have the same voice over dialogue
during a different scene where it seems like the
riddler is trying to call batman using this little
question mark here and hiding his caller id then
the riddler lets him know that he knows his secret
identity calling him bruce wayne saying you're
not as smart as i thought that you were so if it
wasn't clear the riddler does know bruce wayne's
identity if you saw the last trailer video that
i did there's actually some footage that implies
that the riddler knew bruce wayne as a child and
thomas and martha wayne his parents because of the
gotham city orphanage you see the question mark
circling this little boy wearing glasses i believe
that's meant to be riddler as a child but you see
young bruce wayne as a child standing right next
to him in this lineup and thomas and martha wayne
his parents also standing right next to all these
boys so i think what they're trying to imply
is the riddler was raised in the gotham city
orphanage and then later in this trailer where you
see like this riddler graffiti where it all began
that probably has something to do with the gotham
city orphanage in something that happened to him
as a child so the putting a bit of a batman
hush thomas elliott's spin on this version of
the riddler the movie's just borrowing from
a number of batman comic book story lines
i've talked a little bit about this giant easter
egg that they've been putting in all the trailers
here so the sins of my father is a reference to
thomas wayne who actually saved carmine falcone's
life when they were younger so carmine falcone
has sort of had this weird relationship with the
waynes and felt indebted to them and that sort of
carries on with bruce wayne in present day even
though if you've read batman the long halloween
bruce wayne doesn't want to have anything to do
with carmine falcone the no more lies and coulson
references are referenced to the mayor who he
kills like he writes no more lies on his face
and duct tape here this is the mayor's dead body
gil coulson is the city prosecutor who seems like
he's corrupt putting people behind bars for crimes
that they didn't commit savages a reference
to the current police commissioner pete savage
implies that he's sort of connected to carmine
falcone or he's corrupt in some way and renewal
is a lie just sounds like the idea that there's
this renewal that they're trying to hype in
gotham city but that's also being controlled by
carmine falcone in the lie like carmine falcone
and the mob are somehow controlling the renewal of
gotham city they give you a bunch more scenes of
batman with catwoman like they call this trailer
the bat in the cat it seems kind of like they're
at the building where she lives because there
are all these cats around her and she says that
she collects strays i love the way he jokes
too seems like you have a lot of cats here
alfred sort of questions her role in all this
like ah seems like you made a new friend he's like
yeah we'll see if you can't tell on this monitor
behind him here in the bat cave where they're at
this is actually catwoman wearing her wig if
you couldn't tell selena kyle it seems like her
regular job is working at the iceberg lounge for
penguin so i think the idea is that the penguin
during the events of the batman movie is sort of
like an underboss like he's also rising in power
but he's not nearly as powerful as someone like
carmine falcone when you see the riddler in this
giant facility here and then this giant action
scene with batman taking out all of his men this
actually seems like it might be happening a little
bit later in the movie just based on how big
all these explosions are it seems like the riddler
has been broadcasting all of his crimes while he's
committing them like he's live streaming himself
so he's becoming a bit of a pop culture icon in
gotham city rallying support for his cause you see
all the men wearing outfits that are similar to
his with question marks drawn on them like they're
this henchman from the classic batman comics
and the way they've described the film is that
it's sort of like a saw type of game where
you have jigsaw rigging up a couple games that
people have to solve in order to save themselves
so it sounds like the riddler is targeting the
very powerful but corrupt people in gotham and
putting them in traps like the saw movie with
riddles that batman has to solve or they'll die
if batman does not solve the riddles like during
this trailer we hear another new riddle from the
riddler and we actually hear batman solve it which
we haven't heard in the previous trailers is a
pretty simple riddle like you probably figured it
out before batman answered the question himself
the riddler says it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied is violence you may find he's
talking about justice as they intercut with
the footage of the riddler blowing up part
of the gotham city harbor here and what seems
like the sewers where batman is with the police
this is just a longer version of the scene where
the police come to this diner to arrest the
riddler we saw from the last trailer like he's
not wearing his costume here but we see that
batman is there with them while this is happening
when batman is talking to alfred saying all these
years you lied to me it probably has something
to do with what his father did his relationship
with maybe carmine falcone or what his family had
been doing with the philanthropy in gotham city
just their ties to the other corrupt figures in
power like the riddler is somehow implying that
his family is somehow complicit in the bad things
that have happened to gotham city you see a much
bigger team up with catwoman where it seems like
they're taking down riddler's man like i said it
seems like this big action scene is happening
towards the end of the film if you remember one
of the last trailers it also looks like batman
has to stop himself from killing the riddler like
he really unleashes on him and it kind of freaks
catwoman out just a little bit like holy crap this
guy's kind of crazy too but if you spotted any new
easter eggs in the brand new footage that i didn't
talk about during the video just write them below
in the comments like the trailer says the movie's
coming out at the beginning of march so there'll
be a bunch of batman stuff happening really soon
and we'll also probably get some more flash movie
trailer footage with michael keaton's batman when
they start releasing the batman movie so we're
going full batman into the bat verse next year
like we just got spider-man no way home with a
bunch of different versions of spider-man from
the multiverse tobey maguire andrew garfield tom
holland now we're doing the same thing with batman
in a bunch of different universes next year big
reminder the star wars book of boba fett episodes
are starting this week i'll be doing full episode
videos my episode 1 video will post wednesday
after they release it make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss that
everyone click here for my brand new doctor
strange multiverse of madness trailer video
and click here to learn about the alternate ending
for spider-man no way home in all the deleted
scenes thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!